get ready for that puke shot I'm
definitely not a nutritionist but I care
about what my kids eat and what I eat we
get a calendar every month that lists
the breakfast and lunch that she gets at
school and it looks good
I remember the cafeteria lunches growing
up being really bland and dry they
tasted like cardboard she's in the same
school district as I was so hoping they
improved I'm sure there'll be some sort
of combination of process and heated
foods and then maybe like a token
vegetable or fruit this is a substance
I'm not familiar with can somebody tell
me what this is
six glob and it smells like nothing
nothing just tastes like beige seriously
this is what they give it school says
fruits grains vegetables protein dairy
my only question is is if this is what
we're supposed to be eating does this
chicken salad sandwich reflect that
I'm excited about this not at all this
is definitely like a microwave moment
right now I can tell the sandwich looks
like a scrotum meatballs look like bacon
sounds this tastes like it was prepared
maybe a month ago I can plug my nose
when I try it right it's out
no one's season this obviously this is
like tiny water balloons for my mouth
right now and tastes a little dishwater
II very sad corn where did they find
that to fall off a truck or something I
would probably just eat these it's like
a shoelace posing as meat very pliable
aren't they supposed to be orange why
can't I pierce it past a certain point
pretty bendy there's a really an egg
that is disgusting I don't know what
this ham meat is supposed to be I
wouldn't give that to my dog how about
me that's rubber almost 1/5 of the
entire stays sodium in this one packet
that's so bad how did she even eat this
it was actually way worse than I thought
it would be everything felt a little
rubbery I'm really worried that this is
what I depend on while I'm away from her
I just think about the kids who don't
have access to meals and this is how
they're going to eat lunch and I'm just
kind of bummed out because this is what
we're offering them and I think we can
do better we should do better